great sense any comments that you need
to get rid of get rid of them now
and I'm good okay so we will
um commence
the meeting of the or the extraordinary
meeting of the project and finance
committee welcome to all those that have
joined online
um live stream
um
we don't have any Zoom attendees I don't
think no we don't we do have two
apologies one from Mia Clark who is on
Council business
with regards to the energy Forum at
um escort the muraku energy Forum so
he's unable to be with us in the
um councilor pottinger it's a late
apology as well so he won't be joining
us so could I have a mover and a second
for those thanks Leslie thanks
area
don't try and truck me rear with your
hand up and moving and sickening
apologies please
um okay um any Declarations of Interest
with regard to agenda
no thank you
um so we do need to hold our
discussions in public excluded so can I
have a move in a second to move into
public
um thanks Darren thanks Gary all those
in favor
aye minced carried